You know, I keep forgetting that I've left
my face in the middle of that last
scene and I never know what to do
for like that whole twenty five seconds.
So maybe not have that next time. Let's
see. Welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is everybody's favorite day of the week.
This is Thursday, which means it is clustered
day.
We had no episode last week because I
was at DevOps Days in
The UK, but we're back this week and
then hopefully I get to see some of
you all live and in person
at KubeCon and Valencia next week.
Before we get started today, we have a
little bit of housekeeping.
First, it's my pleasure to thank Teleport. They
have been sponsoring a Clustered for a while
now, and we have been using Teleport
since the second episode of Clustered, and I
am continually impressed and amazed
at its wonderfulness. We are able to pair
on Kubernetes
clusters, applications, databases, and Linux systems to fix
all the broken things, which is coincidental considering
we're trying to fix all the broken things
on Azure.
So go to rockload.liveteleport
to support this show. It keeps sponsors happy
and it keeps us doing these episodes. So
thank you very much
Teleport.
I also want to thank Equinix Medal.
They have graciously provided all of the hardware
that we use for clustered for nearly eighteen
over eighteen months now.
There's been hundreds and hundreds of bare metal
machines and bare metal Kubernetes clusters.
So thank you to Equinix Metal. I could
use small virtual machines with a few cores
and a few gig of RAM, but I
don't. I use 48 core machines with 64
gig plus on each node.
Why? Well, it makes it a little bit
more fun.
So I wanna say thank you Equinix Medal.
You can actually use the code Rawkode. I'm
gonna pop that back up. Equinix Medal, can
have an extra second.
Use the code Rawkode because that will get
you $200.
So you can go to console.equinix.com,
use that code, and it means you can
spin up clusters for up to, like, a
hundred hours. And also support the show and
keep the sponsors happy by going to Rawkode.live/metal
to learn more.
Alright. Sponsor message is done. It's now time
to invite today's victims. I mean, wonderful guests.
Oh, we've lost one.
Oh, no. He's gone. Oh, he's back. There
we go. There we go.
Alright. Two wonderful guests today. I'm joined by
John and Marino. Can you both please wave
and say hello?
Hey, everyone.
Alright. Let's start with some quick
we go. Let's start with some quick interruptions.
We'll start with you, but you know, and
then we'll move over. So tell us a
little bit about yourself, please. Yeah. For sure.
Hey, everyone. My name is Marina Widje.
I am a Canadian. I am a father,
husband. I work for solo as a developer
advocate,
and I love all things networking even though
I haven't touched a switcher or router in
probably several years now.
I I work in the service mesh space
and Kubernetes,
so there's a very interesting intersection there where
networking comes into play.
I am excited for today's clustered session even
though I'm probably not sure if I'll make
it out of here, but, looking forward to
the session.
Alright. Thanks for sharing.
Yeah. And I'm John Anderson. I'm a SRE
at Zapier. I'm based out of Puerto Rico.
Clearly by my face, I'm not traditionally from
there, but it's a great place to work
on Kubernetes clusters. I live up in the
jungle.
So it's a good time.
Yeah. And so I'm excited. I walked looked
up Marino on LinkedIn and realized he is
gonna be a formidable opponent, and so I'm
kinda scared right now.
Alright. Awesome.
Alright. Well, thanks for that. And and a
quick question before we dive into fixing some
custard. Are you both gonna be in Cape
Cod Valencia next week?
I am. I will be there. I'm actually
leaving tomorrow
evening catching up, like, because I've got a
conference on Sunday, Cloud Native Rejects. Nice. Doing
a session there,
and then I'll be hanging until KubeCon starts.
So
Awesome. Yeah.
I won't be there, unfortunately. I wanted to,
but I'm in San Diego this week. And
so I was just like told my wife.
I'm like, hey. I'll go to San Diego,
then I'll go to Valencia, then I'll be
home. And she's like, gotta pick. You you're
not doing both.
Alright. Awesome.
Well, let's get this thing
started.
First up, we have
Marino. You ready?
I'm ready. I'm ready. Alright. Let me go
find the active session there. Alright. So I'm
gonna pop open a session on SonTek control
plane one.
I'm using Teleport Connect today, their new desktop
client for Teleport. Let's see how we're going
with this.
We have a session open, but, you know,
you should be able to see that and
join. And if you could just type echo
hello or anything like that to let me
know that you are there.
Alright.
Perfect.
Alright. So you have just over forty minutes.
You have to export your Kube configs to
any aliases, and best of luck.
Alright. Thank you very much.
Let's go ahead and export Kube config.
And I I gotta remember this command now
because I don't remember all these commands at
all times. I I will be honest. I
don't practice
Kubernetes
daily
or on the regular only because
I have so many other things I gotta
worry about.
But
that's not the URL.
I'm, like, trying to copy and paste, and
it's, like, so undecided.
/etc/Kubernetes/admin.com.
There we go. Alright. So let's see. Kubectl
config
view. Let's see what's going on there.
Okay.
So it looks like my cluster is
nothing's messing or messed around here, so let's
just see. Kubectl get nodes.
Okay. Okay. Things are looking good.
Let's just double check some other things. Okay.
Things are looking good. Let's see. Get
all
I'm trying to resize the window when it
was good and painful.
Container status unknown.
Okay.
Interesting.
Alright. So what what I wanna do is
I'm actually gonna describe the container because I
just wanna know what the heck's going on
with the pod I should really take. So
let's just see
a pod that's actually not doing well.
Let's try that.
Container state is unknown. It's not an error
message we see often on clustered.
Yeah. I it's not one that I've actually
ever encountered before,
so it's, rather fascinating.
The container could not be located
when the pod was deleted. The container used
to be running.
Interesting. Okay.
Container
was low on resource, ephemeral storage.
Here. Let's find something else.
Oh, interesting. Okay.
Let's take a look at the deployment
deployment
and see what's going on there.
K.
Deployed
clustered.
And what I'm gonna do is I'm just
gonna output this to YAML and see if
there's anything wrong with the actual
image.
If
you pipe it through less or more, it
just means we can follow along with your
eyes.
Like this.
Perfect.
So
I gotta remember for a second. Is the
Google Cloud registry GCR or GHCR?
The Google Cloud registry is GCR. However, I
use the GitHub container registry for clusters. Oh,
okay. G h c r. Yeah.
Okay. Let's see if there's anything else here.
Okay.
Let's see something else here.
There's no metrics ever deployed to these customers.
That's a good idea, though. I should deploy
a metrics server to these customers.
And there was an interest in error message
and your describe pod, which I think you
may have missed that. Maybe encourage you to
look there again.
Not that the the pod. Yeah.
Alright. Darn it.
Yeah. That's fine.
Alright. Projected volume, multiple sources.
The container could not be located when the
pod was deleted. Was that the area you're
talking about or something? Or the node was
low on resources, ephemeral storage.
Yeah. That
that eviction with the message
had some information there.
Okay. So something to do with the
maybe a PVC or something like that. Well,
read the rest of that line.
Which exceeds its request of zero
using 24
kilo or is it kilobytes or kilobits? I
can't remember. That is
K. Kibibytes. That's just a small yeah. The
I. SI standards.
Otherwise, I think anyone really cares and just
calls the kilobytes anyway, but I I get
semantic over it. Or maybe pedantic is the
correct word. I'm not sure.
Maybe maybe there's something in the deployment,
yeah, that limits how much
storage I can offer.
What volume is it referring to?
This is fun.
I would read that error that's right at
the bottom of the screen. Yeah.
Internal error occurred. Failed calling webhook. Validate Kiverno.
Connection refused. Oh my gosh. Okay. Did y'all,
like, throw a network policy or something in
here?
Can I
get on my Press q two? Quite the
pager.
Just take q?
Yeah. I am.
I'm not taking There we go. Okay. I'll
I'll just do the the q type in.
That must be some sort of really weird
bug. Unless you have, like, the Chromium Vimeo
extension enabled?
No. I don't. Alright. Alright. Alright. We'll see.
Alright.
So something in that error
something in that configuration that was an error
here.
Alright. Hiberno. What does that what does Hiberno
have to do with this?
Did your cluster have Hiberno on it?
I don't recall. I don't think so.
Yeah. I think John's been a bit naughty
with that one.
I don't know. It's a deal.
Get all dash and Kyberno. Because I wanna
I need to see what the heck's going
on in this little namespace.
Pleaded
service
deployment.
Have you used Kiverno before?
No. I haven't. So I unless, like, this
is depend well,
question, you didn't deploy it into our original
clusters. Right? Because I don't have to call
everything. That is correct. This is not part
of the cluster deployment. Caverno is a policy
tool that creates validating and mutating admission controllers.
So if I go ahead and kill this,
then, basically,
I should not have to worry about my
admission issues or anything. Right? Well, I would
check for validate and mutate admission controllers first.
Because even if you remove the Caverno install,
I don't think it will remove those resources.
Alright. They're called validating
oh, what the fuck? Validating web configurations
and mutating web configurations.
Yeah. It's such a long keyword. I'm trying
to remember the actual syntax.
Yeah. I wish it was the short version
of getting them bad. I think they're good.
Jeez, John. You're you're throwing me into an
area I've never ever
Let me just take one and see what
so there's one web webhook in this one.
I have no idea what this policy is
doing.
But I imagine if I delete it and
then go ahead and delete the,
Kiberno namespace, that should resolve things. Right? I'm
hoping. I think so. Yeah. I I back
that plan and go for it.
What's that? I backed that plan 100%. Start
deleting stuff.
Hold on a second. Before I do, though,
what I wanna do is
I just wanna back these up just in
case. I don't know. Who knows what's gonna
happen? I probably only have, like, twenty minutes
left anyways.
No. You're doing good. You've you've got thirty
two minutes left. You're cruising.
Nice. Nice.
YAML
into
actually, hold on before I do that.
K. Paul
dot
YAML.
Let's take this one too,
and then I'll just output it to another
file just because
I don't know.
It doesn't hurt to review them later on.
No. It's very reserved of you.
Validating.
Actually, I gotta fill up this here.
Okay.
Delete.
Validating.
It won't it won't autocomplete a.
Yeah. We'd have to enable autocomplete.
Another thing I should do by default on
these clusters, I don't.
Okay. May maybe for next episode.
Do
you want me to load the auto complete
for you?
Yeah. If you don't mind doing it quickly,
I'll
I'll eventually
Nice. I think I always get that command
wrong too. We're we'll find out.
One quick test is if I just erase
this and do a tab. There we go.
Oh gosh.
Well, I got yeah. It pretty much got
it. Yeah. Yeah. Just just tab your way
through this cluster. That's what I do in
production as well.
Goodbye.
Delete the namespace. I think we could probably
make a coffee now.
Looks like it's gone.
Good. That was quite fast, actually.
No fanalyzer snuck in there then, John.
Yeah. I don't like, I was remembering, like,
when I was messing with the cluster yesterday,
I'm like, we're it was pretty minimal. It
wasn't that much on there. And when I
see Cuyverno there, I'm like, hold on.
Alright. Let's let's try and restart it. Actually,
you know what? Why don't I need to
why don't I need to restart? I'll just
delete the pod, and we'll just redeploy it.
So,
by re by deleting the pod,
because I already have a deployment specified,
I don't need to worry about the pod
recreation. The deployment will automatically spin up the
new pod or the new version. What?
You forgot to put pod.
Oh, yeah. There there we go. Yeah. That
does it too.
Kubectl delete pod, and the name of pod
will allow you to delete the pod. And
if I go back in,
get pods.
Okay. So it's not recreating.
Interesting. K. Let's go take a look and
see
why that might be.
I get pods dash
wide.
The quick test on
NGINX dash dash n equals NGINX. So I
just wanna make sure that it goes into
So I typed this in the chat, but
one thing I noticed is that since this
is running in Cuyverno,
we have a staging and a production cluster,
and we only deployed Kiverno in staging. And
you're supposed to be fixing the production cluster.
Oh, so I shouldn't have deleted Kiverno?
No. You should check your
config context to make sure you're working on
production.
Oh gosh. Did you create another cluster with
the same
node name?
Gosh.
I I I may have.
That's nasty.
Wow.
Well, that is a clustered first.
Nice work.
Dang.
Okay. So, so for those that are watching,
John created a new context,
and I'm logged into it, and I didn't
realize it. And this is why you should
always check your context, like, using a tool
like Kube CTX or what's the new version
of it?
Whatever it is.
K.
So I'm in the right context now, I
would assume. Let me But your engine x
pod is there, so I don't think you
have to use use context.
Oh, yeah. That's right.
Yeah. Kubi is the kubectx
flavor of the week right now. Right?
Yes.
Alright. Kubectl. I got pods.
Oh, okay.
Nodes. So where's the other cluster running, John?
Shit.
It it's actually running at EC two. And,
like, my
heart was beating because the first thing you
guys ran was kubectl config view in the
AWS stuff scrolled by. I'm like, please don't
notice that.
I didn't I understand that.
Let's go back. I never thought it either.
No. Let's do that view config again.
I've never seen anyone run view config as
well. That you got
lucky and unlucky at the same time. Yeah.
I totally didn't notice that. And, you know,
it was really weird. I was when I
was looking at my notes, I noticed AWS
somewhere. I'm like, I was pretty sure we
didn't spin this up on AWS, but
I couldn't think deeply enough about it either.
So, wow, that was that was pretty damn
good. Okay. So now my nodes are not
ready. Interesting.
Let's see.
So I'm gonna describe the node node. Actually,
yeah, let's describe the notice oh, shoot. Because
this has never happened before, technically, if you
had got clustered v two running on his
AWS cluster, you would still have succeeded.
Oh, yeah. That's true. So, actually So which
cluster is less broken, I think, the answer
you should be asking yourself.
The question you should be asking. Time to
delete that other cluster right now. Alright.
So
I've I've got the deployment here. I could
just simply do this. Kubectl
get
SVC as well. And
I could oh, it's a node port. Okay.
So I could just do this.
I'll get s v c clustered
dash o yaml
plus
clustered
s v c dot yaml.
And for the folks on the,
folks on the YouTube here listening or watching
in on YouTube, what I'm gonna try to
do is get this quickly up and running
on that cluster that we think is working.
So we'll see how that runs.
But I gotta export a whole bunch of
services so that I got files that I
can work off of.
Postgres
dash dash dash dash o vmlpg.pg
s v c dot e m l
m c t l get
deploy.
So what's wrong with the current cluster?
I'm not sure. The nodes are down,
and, I was just describing one of the
nodes.
I think I described the control plane. Node
is now has its sufficient node has sufficient
memory.
Node has no disk pressure starting Kubelet. Invalid
capacity zero on image file system.
So you may wanna jump on to that
worker node.
Yeah.
Let me open a session.
Actually,
can I SSH to it or no?
Well, I've just opened the session. So if
you go to active sessions, you'll be able
to see worker one session, and then you
can type with me there.
Okay. Let me load that up. Alright.
Hello.
K. Cool.
So it said image disk capacity is zero.
So I think we need start looking at
the disks on this machine.
How the heck do I do that?
We could use d u.
D u. Okay.
Oh, wait. That's for files. Right? D f
is the one I meant. Oh, there we
go.
Yeah. There's some pretty full disk guy stuff
going on here. Right?
Yeah. It's pretty at
oh my gosh.
What the heck can we get rid of?
Well, ironically, the first command I run could
probably help us with that.
D u.
Are you familiar with d u at all?
Not
really.
Alright.
Oh, we're not in the so d u,
we can do depth one dash eight versus
human readable size, which will give us a
rough indication of where the large thing is
are.
Mhmm.
Because see that bar has 387
gig. So then we could jump into slash
bar and kinda chase
it that way.
We could maybe also use a thing to
look for files larger than a certain size,
but I don't know if he's did a
saturation attack with many loads of small files
or if he's done something,
Maybe he just did a DD four gig
block size. Who knows? Like, I don't know
how nasty John is here.
So we
could do another, what, d
You could do a DU and change the
depth from one to two or three and
then try and get a look at the
folders and try and see if you can
work out with all this crap.
Let's try.
So one will show you the top level.
Three will break it down a bit further.
So what what what is that? Slash our
log seems to be pretty chunky.
Let me just sorry. Did you say bar
log? Yep. If you went to the log
directory.
And you see that. Where are you seeing
that?
Oh, run
your d u command again and just type
it in grep for log, and you'll get
the size.
You forgot.
We go.
Oh, this loads. But you can see the
second bottom line.
Yeah. Right there. Right? Down to that directory,
it's got, like, the 80 gig in it.
So So could I just delete that? Like,
goodbye?
I mean, you could blow away that entire
directory, but let's maybe take a look inside
it first.
Try
maybe do a directory listing with
sort by size or something.
Yeah. There's there's some chunky
and I like the naming of those big
files too. It's very appropriate.
Yeah. It's always Log four j.
Alright. Let's let's see if we can do
an RM on these bad boys.
Good lord. Why is it taking so long
to delete?
Alright. Let's see.
Oh, what? Oh, yeah. I need the arm.
Let's
see. Alright.
Maybe maybe we should be able to
well, I I wanna have to go back
to the other session. Let's just hope he's
not reformatted the desk to set FS, causing
the delete, not really to free up the
space. But I'm assuming that would be a
step too far.
Yeah.
Alright. So
node, they're still not ready. Let's describe the
node.
We'll bring you back another session.
Yeah. I'm back in the other session. Sweet.
Kubelet node
Twenty minutes to go.
Oh my gosh. Node SonTek. ProPlane one status
is now. Node has sufficient memory.
Node has no disk pressure. Where did you
run that? Sorry. I don't see that.
What's that? Can you run the command again?
Am I we yeah.
Pass it through the pager so we can
see the scroll. Yeah. There we go.
I screwed up.
Invalid disk capacity. Oh my gosh. Still?
But this is describing the control plane, though.
Is it?
I don't know. Well, hold on. Let me
see what because my skin's a bit weird.
Yeah. You described the control plane,
which may also have filters. We wanna try
describing the worker.
Mhmm.
So
let me My my screen's gone a bit
funky, so I'm just gonna take reset to
there we go. I'm
done.
Yeah. So let's describe that worker and see
if we can see at least the that
node's ready again because
that would be good step forward.
Sorry. What was that?
Describe worker one to or get a run
get node to see if it's healthy. I
would expect worker one not to be complaining
about the image capacity.
Yeah. It's still describe
some
tech worker.
Which one?
What? Node.
Yeah. It's probably the word node in there.
Oh my gosh.
Right. These cycles ago, invalid capacity zero and
image fail system.
Yeah. Can you scroll up?
I
expect
so all of those are not what the
actual problem is right now.
Expect it should tell you what the problem
is up higher, but that
it's been complaining for those for a while.
We might need to pass it through less.
Yeah. Let's do that.
Okay. Here we go. So Liam is up.
Memory pressure.
Oops.
Could've been already
let's see.
No taints.
It's
not that it's not schedulable.
That looks okay so far. The important part
there is kubelet not ready.
Ah, okay.
Then how are we getting a report on
the status?
Kubelet is ready.
That's what I want you to think.
We should check on the worker.
That's
a good point. Okay. So I'm switching over
to the worker now.
System
CTL
status
Kubelet
running too. Hold on. Wait. Let's see.
Doesn't seem to be anything wrong with it.
Am I not seeing something here?
We may have to get the logs from
the queue, but I'm not seeing anything right
now.
I'm curious about that infection hard
warning,
but I'm
not sure if that's normal or not. So
the command I just ran for those on
the
on the YouTube channel there watching in, I
ran something called journal CTL dash u kubelet,
which gives me some more logging information about
the kubelet itself
to give me some details about
maybe some files that might be misconfigured or
something along those lines.
That's I think it's interesting,
the fact that our Kubelet is using a
a memory state store.
I
don't know if that's normal.
Sorry. What was that again? It says initialized
new in memory state store, which may be
compared to normal, and I've always skipped it.
But because we're seeing memory things or disk
things, I'm curious about it.
Well, I don't spend a lot of time
in the kubit logs. Why would you?
Yeah. Okay. I don't know where else to
look now.
The the log should be the right place.
I would just say scroll through here. It
should show you what the problem is.
Waiting for nodes sync container runtime initializer,
starting to listen address.
I feel like something was wrong here.
Container runtime network is not ready. Network ready.
Network ready equals false reason. Adding debug handlers
too. What's the reason?
Yeah. Let's try running it again, seeing if
we could get some more messages.
Interesting.
Error getting node. Error node SonTek dash worker
dash one not found.
And that means it's not able to because
our kubel is not online. It's not speaking
to the API server. So I think that's
normal at the start.
Can you tail the logs? I think we're
missing the error since it's we're only getting
a
snapshot in time.
Just do, like, minus flu instead of minus
u. Just do minus f l u,
and that'll tail it so that we can
see there.
There we go.
Hold on. I'm having a hard time finding
it. Hold on. Yeah. I would kill the
tail now. Yeah. There you go.
Okay. So where did I run the tail?
So the adder's right there and
failed to start container manager, invalid node allocatable
configuration.
Resource memory has an allocatable of blah
and capacity of blah.
I'm I'm literally trying to find this message
that I cannot see because I'm looking at
a
to start container manager invalid node allocatable. Oh,
there we go.
Oh my gosh.
What does this even mean?
I
mean, I I I I don't know right
now.
I think what we need to do I'm
assuming he's modified the Kubelet configuration, which means
we wanna start looking at system control cat
kubelet and see if he's added any extra
flags to limit
capacity.
What else could this be? It could be
where is the file located at? I can't
remember now.
Here. Right?
If you're in system control cat, it'll tell
you all the config files that are used.
Sorry. What was the command again? System control
space cat space and then the unit name,
which is kubelet.
Okay.
Here we go. So this will show you
the unit file, which looks
looks clean.
And then we have the
far left kubelet config dot YAML fail here.
We have the QBDM flags ENV,
and we have the eccentric kubelet.
An interesting comment on the chat as well
from one thousand and one saying this could
potentially be container d related as well.
Container d?
Yeah.
So we should probably sanitize each of these
files and then take a look at the
container d config.
I am I am of the mindset that
we could probably
hold on a second.
The files are located here in Kubelet.
Oh.
The first one is bar lib kubelet config
dot YAML.
Lib kubelet.
Oh, yeah. Config dot yaml. Maybe just cut
that.
Now you have to try and remember what
is normal in this file.
Help find address.
I think. I
think that's okay.
Okay.
And if you run the cat again, we
can look at the next file.
Sorry. The system control cat. There's another two
conflict files. I don't remember where they are.
What's the file we wanna look at? Kubelet.
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Kubelet. Now we've got this
varlib
kubelet flags.
I'll just cut that.
And that looks
clean.
Yeah. That looks good to me. And then
the next file we need to look at
is the environment file.
Yeah. The Etsy default kubelet. We could take
a peek in there and see.
There we go.
We got extra args. Eviction hard memory dot
available less than a hundred gigs.
So this is telling the cubelet to evict
all pods if there's less than 100 gig
of available memory.
Wow. Okay. So we can delete that, I
guess. You can indeed delete that. Yeah.
What I'm And I will have to do
a
restart of the.
And if you jump back to the control
Jump back to control plane and try to
get nodes, and we'll see.
Still not ready. But Yeah. Let's give it
five seconds.
It's gonna be ready.
Yeah. That that's all there was for making
it not ready, so it should come back.
Hey. Hey.
The worker's good, but not the, control plane.
Oh, we don't need that control plane.
It's
not a part, but it's the same break,
so you can fix it quickly.
Okay.
Hold on. Let's
see what I did. So I actually went
into which file again?
It was u r m slash e t
c slash default slash kubelet.
Yeah.
System CTL
restart.
Kubelet.
And then kubectl get nodes.
Already.
That's a watch.
Let's wait for it to change.
Eventually, it'll change.
Hopefully, it'll change.
There we go.
Alright. Alright. Well, let's take a look at
our deployments.
Get deploy.
Why not? Available.
That's good.
K. Get SBC.
Yeah. That's a node port.
And what did you want me to upgrade
it to? Version two or something? You have
to upgrade our cluster deployment from m h
v one to m h v two.
Alright. Let me just
And you've got six and a half minutes.
Okay.
Let
it deploy
clustered.
Nothing.
Darn. Why didn't we update?
I was worried that was gonna work.
Yeah. I mean, you could try the edit
deploy again. Something tells me the edit oh,
it did go through.
Do we have a a new replica set?
We
do not. No.
Now what happened?
Could CTL
edit the flow actually, let's just get the
deploy.
Deploy.
Actually
So I can give a hint for this
one.
So the replica sets are managed by a
thing called the cube controller manager.
Yeah. And so if we're not getting new
one of those, you're gonna wanna make sure.
Yeah.
Wait. We're getting a new one of what?
Yeah. So there's
are
you familiar with the Kube controller manager?
I messed around with it, like, a long
time ago. So Yeah. If if you go
look at the static manifest, I think you'll
you'll try.
So the
one second. It's a Etsy Kubernetes manifest. Right?
That's the one.
This is one of the weirdest things about
Kubernetes. And, actually, I talk about this the
talk I did at DevOpsDays Birmingham last week.
I was talking about the KubeControlManager
how you can disable replica sets and pods.
And I'm just thinking, like why?
Why do these flags exist? But of course
there are always use cases.
But yeah, it's always a sneaky break.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, past it. I'll
tell you, this is sneakier than you're gonna
expect.
Oh, it is. I expected to see a
dash replica set controller thing there.
If you check the cube controller logs, it'll
at least tell you what the problem is.
Oh, gosh.
It would have been faster just to deploy
the new cluster that you create.
Start
with cube 80 every set. It's always the
best way.
Alright. Let's check the logs for this kubectroller
manager and
see what's happening because I have no idea.
Sorry. What's the command to run through the
logs again? For this, because it's a static
pod, you need to go to bar log
containers.
You can also use cube CTL logs on
it because it's inside the cube system namespace.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
Pawn station Kube system.
Kube logs.
That's a good point. Oh, yeah. Okay. I
just noticed something here.
You've got the namespace.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Noise.
There's so much noise.
That's not noise.
That's information.
We're retrieving resource block system. Lease
coordination
is forbidden system.
What?
Okay.
I feel like I'm so close.
So Kubernetes
I mean, I'm guessing, and I'm I'm explaining
this to myself to see if this even
makes sense. But Kubernetes
API
supports leader elections, so the releases
thing, and it looks like
have you modified the RBAC
of the role for the controller manager to
not have access to the leases
object? Leader election was true.
Right? I made it look like I did.
You can turn the laser light off because
there's
only one.
Right?
Is that what you've done?
No. So
yeah. So since we're getting close to time.
So the way this is working
oh, we'll we'll see if he
it it's sitting right in front of you
right now.
It's right in front of you. Oh, he's
been in the wrong
authentication
for the controller manager.
Right?
You're meant in the scheduler instead of the
controller manager.
Yeah. The error is saying that the scheduler
can't get these leases.
You're not supposed to be working as scheduler.
Yeah. Go down four lines, but, you know,
that scheduler.com
should be controller-manager.com.
Control Oh.
You know, you could've given me an error.
I don't think I would've seen that.
I
tried it on two of my friends before
this to see if they figured out, and
they couldn't. So I'm like, this is a
good one. This service is really interesting.
I don't know if it's cube controller manager
or just controller manager.
I just okay. We may have to check.
But you can save it either way and
then and look in that directory and see
what file exists.
This is l s. I think it's cube
controller manager.
So you were right the first time when
you listened to me. That was your big
mistake.
Very good. Very good. Okay.
Alright.
If you restart the Kiplet, it will speed
that controller manager redeploy up.
Alright.
Done.
No. It's not. I feel like done.
Yeah. I was gonna say there's one more,
and then you're done. Sorry.
This is literally death by a thousand cuts.
Is it like okay. Here's the thing. I
don't know if it's in the deploy.
But do we have a new replica set
yet?
Actually, that's a good point.
Nope.
Alright. And did the controller manager restart if
you check the cube system namespace?
Yeah. You should have a new replica set.
Well, maybe not. Oh. No. We're crash it.
So that maybe it was controller manager, not
controller manager. Doing l s slash u t
c Kubernetes.
I'm assuming that's the fail not found error.
No. Just Kubernetes.
Yeah. Just inside Kubernetes. I'd say Kubernetes.
We're looking at the
it is Kubernetes.
Alright. You'll need to get the logs on
that control manager, and we'll see what it's
complaining about. We'll we'll go for a few
more minutes, and we'll see if we can
work it out.
Yeah. That should be working now. So you
might just have to
that was just thirty seconds ago. Yeah. So
there must be a typo on that line
we modified.
Yeah. It's not picking up that fail.
Yeah. Cat dot config. Let's figure out there
must be a missing character
or something. Cube
controller.
So
go to the top of this file. It
has the correct one.
And then we can just copy it from
there. Yeah. Right there. Oh, controller manager. Okay.
So it's not cube controller manager.
How did we look at the file system
and still think it was cube controller manager?
Don't know. Because the whole verified this.
Oh, no. We looked at the manifest. The
manifest is cube, but the actual comp is
not. Yeah. We looked at the No. We
could oh, there's two. That's why. There's the
cubecontrollermanager.com
and a controllermanager.com.
See?
No new replica set.
You may have to restart you, but I
can from that controller manager as well. Oh,
it's happy. Okay. Cool.
I'll do this.
Boom.
CTO rollout.
Alright. So give you the final hint because
we're close though we're out of time. The
scheduler is your your final issue.
Looks
but
it looks healthy.
You might see a trend with these breaks.
Everything looks healthy.
Action.
Just to see. I want it
he's not gonna tell me anything here.
Replica
sets don't need scheduled. So why do we
not have a new replica set? Oh, that's
true. We should have a new replica set
at this point.
Not the controller manager. Oh, we do know.
Alright. Okay. Okay. So how many pods do
we have?
Right. Okay. Now we can describe the new
replica set, and we can see what the
hell's going on there. Oh, it says forty
seconds. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Might
be okay.
Alright. Let's just do that. Yeah.
How do I get to the okay. One
second. Could CTL get
SCC?
Or am I pasting this in to my
web browser?
You can curl
local host 30,000. It doesn't work in my
browser, but sometimes that does happen. I need
to work on that.
Yeah, local host 30,000, see if we get
v two.
We do. Nice.
There you go. Your scheduler break did not
take.
Hang on. I I did that one on
Adobe, and it didn't work out that either.
I need to get better at it.
That was good. Oh my gosh. Oh my
gosh.
Alright.
Whoo.
That was interesting. Thanks so much for that.
Yeah. That
meant in the wrong
cube config and to the container.
Gives you, like, a kill effect because it
looks like something we've seen before and then
was and and it just completely different. That
was
evil,
but
fun. I enjoyed it. Thank you so much.
Alright. Great work, Marina.
And I I love the way you were
talking and explaining things as you went as
well, which is just fantastic. So nice work.
Alright. It's time to swap hot seats. John,
you are up.
Rock and roll, man. You got this. I
I I like the other side better.
I don't want I don't wanna do this.
Alright. I have opened
well, opening an SSE session on the control
plane. Please feel free to join the session
and give me an echo or something to
let me know that you are there.
And we'll get this thing started.
Sweet. You have forty just over forty one
minutes. Export your KubeConfig, set up any aliases,
and best of luck.
Russell was waiting on the the Rawkode schedule
there. We don't need to bust that one
out today.
You're supposed to need it, though. That's
unfortunate.
Alright. So
let's look. Did you did you install a
tool just now?
I
just, you know, some small small scripts. Nothing.
Ignore. Ignore. Oh, you just saw the air.
Oh, okay. There you go. Nothing to see
here. Okay. You're on control.
You're on JK. You're on CT control. You're
on helm. You set up your alias.
Yep. So Look. You were looking for policies.
Yeah.
I
after last time, I'm like, yeah. I'm checking
for all kinds of stuff.
Alright. So
that means the API server is not up.
So
alright. Yeah. Let's
we have a kubelet, but we don't have
a kubelet API server for some reason. So
for our log containers,
why aren't you working?
Uh-oh. So
alright.
Hopefully, it's
still there.
Manifest.
Alright.
And so we should have set PKI in
there,
and they're called API server.
Okay.
So let's
see what it's what was the error? PKI
API server etcd client.
Is that different?
Yeah. So that's not there.
So what is
oh, there's two.
Yeah. There's two s's there. Okay.
That was confusing. I'm like, it looks like
it's there.
Alright. So we got two s's there.
Oh, I just deleted the wrong thing, didn't
I?
Yep.
Yep. I was I searched for two s's.
Turns out in English, you can't have two
s's.
Yeah. Quite common.
Alright.
Let's see the
CA file. Okay. So I'm there we go.
That's the right one.
I almost made things worse.
Yep. That happened.
That would've been harder to detect.
Alright.
Just give it a little poke,
and then
alright. So it hasn't changed.
So
And you'll move it and put it back,
Drake, as well.
Although the tail that you've got, the container
ID will change.
Yeah. Well, I did star, so I should've
got them all. Alright.
Oh, yeah. But the star was always at
that time.
So when then Yeah.
Interesting.
So
yeah. So it still didn't pick up that
change. Let me look back at it.
Didn't pick up my change here,
but I did save it.
Another way to get logs is varlog
pod. Mhmm. Yeah. Which just means you don't
have to worry about the container ID changing
too much.
Yeah.
No.
We got all of these, though. So I
would need to know which one. Alright.
Alright. I'll try to be helpful. I thought
you're getting.
Alright. So I have
I have a cubelet.
I'm not getting oh, what I could do
was it
so I don't have a Kube API server.
So it's still not starting it up even
though
I fixed the thing it's complaining about.
Yep.
That's annoying.
So
there's those logs.
So it's doing that because it's not starting
up. So for some reason, it's not starting.
Let's go back to the manifest
API server.
It says command QPA
API server, which is probably correct.
I feel like you're making some assumptions right
now.
So?
Yeah.
I mean, I I I'm 100% speculating, but
you've made one assumption, which I would probably
wanna confirm if I were you.
Well, I don't know what that assumption is,
but, like, what I've noticed so far is
API server is not running. Right? But I
do have a Kubelet up.
Well, if you modify a static manifest, then
you don't see that change happen.
Yeah.
Yeah. You're that is an assumption I shouldn't
be making.
You're you're right.
System CTO.
Good call. I would have been spinning my
wheels for a while if that's
let's actually look at that.
So I can't see my whole screen. I'm
gonna wiggle this so I can Yeah. Wiggle
it and type reset. Maybe it doesn't know.
Kickstart it. Yeah.
So let's
see if I can And if anyone wants
to rewrite Xterm GS, we'd all appreciate it.
That would be
that would be awesome.
That's, like, Toml. Yeah. This guy. Very.
Oh, that's a great place, though.
It's in Kubernetes manifest.
Right?
I don't know. My screen's gone a bit
funny on me now. Okay.
So, yeah, it's looking in the right place
unless there's a way to override it
outside of that
because we got static pad pad
path here,
which is correct.
Let's run that cat again.
So we can check we can check one
little hint.
Take a look at that error message when
you run that kubectl command.
Which command? But he's done a PS, and
there's no API server yet. Just
throwing that out there. Yeah. That too. Okay.
There yeah. There's something else that you'll have
to fix. But
Don't don't make it too easy on him.
Come on. You see what he did? Yeah.
That's true. Yeah. You're an s r. You
can hear me.
Alright. So you've confirmed that the static manifest
location has not been tampered with.
Alright. So we do have some extra ARGs,
which we don't want as well. So we'll
kill those off.
Which shouldn't
affect what we're doing right now.
And then I also wanna check
I just resized my window. I hope it
doesn't Nope. It's alright. It came back.
I've been trying to drag the bottom of
it for, like, the last three minutes. I
just I was just like, screw it. I'm
just gonna resize the thing.
Alright. So and all this looks okay.
Okay.
So let's
Still don't have API.
And you're not getting any logs
from it at all? Yeah. So that's what
I'm wondering. Like, if I go to bar
log
containers
and
queue API
server,
and then get all those. Yeah. So it
hasn't logged out since
that time that I Yeah. So it hasn't
even tried to start it yet.
So
what would
what would cause it to not try to
start a Kube API server?
Yeah. You even moved the file, and you
restarted to Kubler. Right? So Yep.
Yeah. Kubler's been running for one minute.
Yeah. It's user in.
Check here.
Are there any sort of, perhaps,
certificates
that might impact
how all of this might come up?
It shouldn't stop the API server for starting
because the kiblet reads the static manifest directory
and create something called a Metapod, which doesn't
require
yeah. It shouldn't require it doesn't require any
authentication. Those containers should just be created. Right?
Yeah. That's what yeah. I'm not sure. Like,
since he's given us a hint, I'm questioning
my
my assumptions here.
But my assumption would be even if it
was a certificate problem, it would try to
start it up and then
Yeah. We see logs.
Yeah. And we're not getting logs right now.
What about our Kubelet logs? Did that give
you anything?
Let's
let's
look.
There we go.
Not found. Alright. Oh, slow down.
It's usually a good idea to restart the
Kubelet and just
go through those logs so you see everything.
Because a lot of the times, you get
errors early if they never come back.
I'll just let her go for a little
bit.
Alright.
What do got here? Unable to register node
with API server.
Connection refused.
No. No. I think that was because Keybaby
BI server actually wasn't up. So some of
those errors oh, there we go.
CA certs.
Etsy PKI.
So, yeah, those are kind of interesting since
he mentioned the certificates. Right?
Mhmm.
Sure. Plan. Yeah. So,
yeah, that's the only thing I'm seeing in
there. I'll check a little bit more. But
yeah. A lot there at all. No.
But I also don't see any
header message with regards to certificate.
Hey. Did you also check to make sure
that you're right on you're on the right
context?
Did we both do that?
I don't see it.
Yeah. Yeah.
I was gonna be like, I thought I
was clever.
Alright. Alright.
Yeah. So what
let's go back to these manifests.
So because we should be starting the API
server, and you gave the hint of the
certs.
I would really expect a log for those.
So it's really interesting that it's failing to
start
the API server. I would expect log. I
mean, we don't even have any
containers or container d. Right?
Yeah. So oh, here. Let me look at
here. I'll show you. So, yeah, if you
do this,
we just don't have the Kube API server
currently.
So let's oh, here.
I I was scrolling here. I'll just pass
this to Les.
So because, yeah, these are the only things
I'm seeing, but
they don't seem like a problem.
Well, yeah, because the API server is not
running. So that's exactly, but, I mean, I
don't see it starting the matter pod either.
There's normally a line at the start of
the kubelet that says read manifest in this
location. I mean, do we have that?
Can you find manifest?
Yeah. Right there.
Let's see Kubernetes manifest. So it's looking in
the right place,
and then it's starting the kubelet.
It's still on the the volume manager.
Oh, I thought I was. Yeah. Yeah. Oh.
Yeah. It's right here. My
terminal scrolls all the way back to the
bottom. Oh, interesting. Okay.
Yeah. So all that looks correct. Runtime status.
I don't know.
Like, let's select 2379.
Is there anything in there for that?
Nope.
So because what I was wondering is, like,
do we have, like, etcd? Yeah. So we
have etcd running and everything. So it's only
the Quby API server is not starting.
So what would stop the Quby API server
from starting?
It must be missing. Oh, right here. Nope.
Wait. I see it.
So, yeah, it's gonna crash loop back off.
It it's halfway through.
I don't know if can you see
yeah. I don't know how to tell you
where I'm looking at. But there's a there's
a crash loop back off here.
But that was here. I'll just grab it
so you can see.
Alright. Okay.
There we go.
It should not be that hard to get
that lane out of that log file. Yeah.
Okay. So, yeah, it's a back off starting
QAPI server.
But, yeah, but we're running lot. Container.
Yeah. So it's failing to start it, but
why?
Let's see. Yes.
Assuming the correct thing. If not present,
I'm gonna just put this as always just
to be safe.
Yeah. I would expect a log here. Oh,
but I guess since it's failing to start
the container, it's not gonna have us a
log. Okay. That makes sense.
So I think I think that's what's happening.
Yeah. Yeah.
So
now the question is why is it failing
to start that container?
If you do a PS dash all, does
it show you nonrunning
containers?
Can I control PS dash Oh?
Alright. There we go. So we got two
x eight kubi API servers. Maybe Yeah. I'll
get the logs of Yeah.
Okay.
About a minute ago. Or even run an
inspect on that one that failed a minute
ago. Maybe useful.
Yeah. So it's
there we go. Oh, but that's the old
one. Old one.
Yeah.
So let's do this new one.
Alright. There we go. Let's see. That's a
good one. Alright.
Loaded 11, validating admission controllers successfully.
Oh. The trailing data is the the secret
sauce there.
Yeah.
So command failed, X509, trailing data.
Bowie. So one of the certificates is wrong,
but which one?
Cat them all.
Yeah. So,
c d p k I. Alright.
So
I I don't know if this is gonna
actually work,
but maybe they put something in there.
It doesn't look like they actually did put
anything in there. I'm
terrible at certs, so I don't know if
there's a way to like, I would have
to use OpenSSL's
x five zero nine to decrypt them if
we wanna actually see the data inside.
Oh, let's do
LS.
I mean, the API server entity client, those
there has been modified.
So
let's see. Seventeen forty two. Yeah. So this
is the only one that's been modified right
now. Have you opened it in
them? What was
the right thing? Okay. I opened all of
them.
Alright. So I'll get this.
Ah, look there. It's right in front of
our face. He's sneaky.
I'll give you a minute. Yeah.
It's not in front of my head, bro.
Read the last line.
The second last line. Sorry. The last line,
I think. Oh, yep. Yep. Yep. You're right.
Oh, no. Totally all of it. Oh, I
already did.
Oh, that that may be broken. That's broken
now.
I think one second. Maybe just to delete
that. I hope you find this. Yeah.
Right now.
Right.
It broke it, so I have to fix
it.
K.
It says search renew.
I figured that wrong.
No. What is it?
Yeah. Keep it in it. So it's the
phase is scarce. I don't think you need
to type phase.
No?
Thought that's what it was.
Help.
Yeah. Sercs. Sercs.
And then renew.
That's what I said.
In sub command Oh, you have to do
you have to fill it with Serc.
Yep. So
what was that one that I just broke?
API server entity client.
But is it the file name that we
do?
It's API server. Right?
Yeah. The API server dash entity dash client.
I don't think you could put
Okay.
Yeah. Upload existing You may have to remove
that one now because it Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Would it.
You made it worse.
Okay. So
I think we're good now. Right?
Nope.
We don't have our.
No. So how am I gonna regenerate that
now that I jacked it up? Oh, actually,
here. Can we
I know how we can do it.
Alright. I got this.
Which one was it? I forget. I need
to go back. API-entity-client.crt.
Yeah. So it did regenerate it. Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh,
did you scroll back up to get the
data?
Yeah.
I was like, I know I know I
can't edit before I deleted it. That was
called backup. Alright.
Good form of backup.
Never clear your screen. That's the secret here.
Alright.
So now,
we wanna do this again.
Oh,
yeah. So PS minus a.
Seven minutes ago.
So we're gonna wanna
because all we did was minus minus modify
a cert. So it's not gonna know that
we did that. Right? Yep. Twenty minutes to
go.
Alright. So now that we fixed
that, is it gonna spin one up?
Get rid of the minus a.
It did. It's running.
337.
That's not right.
Alright.
Only one place.
143.
Oh, PDO.
Right. We're getting somewhere now. You have an
API server.
You have broken things there then.
One core DNS broken, but there's one up
as well. So that's semi suspicious, and then
same thing for the serial operator. But,
we're gonna focus on the clustered
for now.
See if that's the right choice. Oh, maybe
not. Network is not ready.
CNI plugin is not initialized.
And then this one,
both of those are interesting. Right?
Failed to fetch token.
Yeah.
Curious about the age on those adders, though.
Like
Yeah. They were a while ago.
You just go straight for the update?
Yeah. Let's not debug stuff that I don't
want.
Alright. Creating.
Got a new replica set.
Something tells me that pause is never gonna
come.
Oh, Alright. So let's do
Just
to get
a clean.
Alright. Do you know you don't need to
grace period equals zero anymore? That used to
be mandatory for a force, but it's been
it's been Oh, they got rid of it.
They got rid
Alright.
So these are creating now. So it seems
like it's getting stuck in creating.
So that means, like, that pause container or
something. Right?
See what it says.
Oh, there we go. Failed
to set up network for sandbox.
Alright. I'll open a session on the worker
node for you. Assuming you want one. Yeah.
Yeah. I let's see.
You got it? Oh, there. Yeah. It's there.
Joining
now.
Okay.
Given everything's running,
so I don't know where to fix that,
though, because we're we have a real network
over here. We just need to fix what
the sandbox is doing,
but I don't know where to go for
that.
So what happens when
you deploy the CNA is it puts some
config and some binaries onto the host.
Yep.
My
thinking was maybe they had modified something in
there.
Yeah. So I can compare
the other one.
Zero three one Cilium.
Yeah. That all looks correct.
Yeah. Actually, it says incompatible CNA versions. The
config is one zero zero, and the plug
in support zero c one. So what's on
the host is right?
Alright.
One second. So go back here. Config, man?
Yeah. So config
is 100.
But yeah. So we're on 031
on ours.
So
It's system.
Ah, okay.
Now is they were doing one zero o?
I believe so.
Nothing in there.
So where else? Oh, here. Instead of editing
it.
Yeah. So where would you define
that version if it's not in
CNI?
That's our only CNI. Oh, well,
what is the correct I don't even know
what the correct version is. Like, should we
be one o, or is zero three one
the right thing?
I think c o c one is the
correct one.
Okay. So we need to find
where happening during
o. Creating a pod sandbox.
Yeah. And there's nothing in the configuration that's
defining that.
Must be either Container d. Container d or
the Kipling. Yeah.
So
what is it? Container
d Config dump. Config dump.
Nothing. So they didn't modify container d. Oh,
yep. Yep. Yep. Let's go check over there.
Alright. Going back over to the worker.
Is it over there,
So how could you modify container d or
what else could it be?
Trying to think what
So it sounds like the Kubect config is
one option, but it could be container d's
unit fail. Maybe cat is at the service.
If you think it's contingency, I'm not sure.
Yeah.
No. That's pretty vanilla. Right?
Yeah. That's pretty.
So what I was thinking is, like, inside
here,
we have, like, the plugins.
Yeah.
So,
yeah, I'm not sure what Private conflict dot
YAML. Just capture.
So not some sort of c and I
thing in here.
No.
Nothing.
Let me do that there. Let's do it
here.
Oh, so,
yeah, I'm not sure. Oh, I'm in the
wrong place now. I'm gonna go back to
the master for a second.
System. Yeah. For here, I'm not really sure
what would define
that version. I'm gonna reread that error.
Maybe describe
the daemon set for Cilium.
Could it be modifying the orgs or something?
Yeah. So it says failed to create the
sandbox,
failed to set up network for sandbox, and
then it says an incompatible CNI version.
Yeah. Tricky.
So that has some mounts in it.
I mean, it's passed an eyeball test.
Don't see I
was scrolling. I wasn't using
Yeah. I'm I'm scrolling too. I'm I'm I'm
suckered onto this. I need to know what
this is.
This is an interesting one. So I'm trying
to think of, like, when the sandbox starts
up.
There's this Yeah. Cilium custom CNI con. Oh,
that's just our config, though. So
Yeah.
Cilium custom CNI con, and it's a config
map, which oh, yeah. And we actually
We looked at that. Yeah. K. Get Centimeters.
So we've got Cilium config.
We've got yeah.
Well, we can relook at this just to
make sure we didn't miss anything.
But it doesn't seem like that's it.
I guess the question would be, is there,
like, supposed to be a default flag in
here and it, like, defaults to one o
if you don't have it, but that would
be kinda weird.
Let's see. Let's think. Pod Sandbox.
Alright. So yeah.
So pod sandbox.
Yeah. Without a container d modification, that's interesting.
I just ran container d. I've done that
so many times. Yeah. It doesn't that doesn't
respect the signals.
Yeah.
You just have to open a new session
and kill nine that. No.
I think we're I just think you can
stay there. Right? Okay. Yeah. We're good. So
I did for future reference, I did control
backslash,
which is a bigger kill than a control
c, and that seemed to The control c
is, like, in what's the backslash? Is that
straight into a sick kill?
I think so. Yeah. I I forget at
this point. I've just been using it so
long. I just when control c doesn't work,
I control backslash. I didn't know that. Fair
enough. Alright.
So
something
with the sandbox.
Trying to think. What else?
I mean, this could be completely have. A
left field, and I I maybe they're not
this nasty. Not this nasty. But can we
go into the c and I directory and
actually run the binaries for the dash dash
version?
Like, could they have recompiled anything? Which seems
I think it's a
where did they put the bins? C and
I?
So the the one hint I'll drop y'all,
right, is
think of dependencies for a second,
and then also think about release notes. And
that's all I'm gonna say.
Yeah. That's the same CNI has been recompiled.
That's been modified.
Yeah. That's Let's run a dash dash version
on that.
Like, run. Yeah.
Yeah.
That looks okay. CNI bucket at one ten.
Yeah. So
we're gonna like, what is the I wanna
just go to Cilium and, like, look. What
is the version we're supposed to be on?
Yeah. So they're one o. So that configuration,
I think I think we're chasing our tail.
I think 013
is wrong. Right? Because they're on one eleven
right now
if you look at Sillyam's release docs. So
you can remove alright. I think you can
run Rawkode, C and I, and restart the
cinemapods
if you want them to redo everything fresh,
I think.
Yeah. So
oops.
You're thinking, like, deleting the config right here?
No. I was going to delete every single
binary and opts, but I see an event
and then restart the so it
redownloads them all.
Because that's what happens when this when starts
as a daemon set, it pulls down all
the binaries that are needed for it to
work.
That was nice. I didn't get rid of
it. Okay.
And so
But did you get rid of every binary,
or did you just get rid of the
one?
Only Cilium was modified. So if you come
back here to see time stamps on the
old ones are 2020. So did they replace
them all with old version except for the
Cilium c and I, which is why we're
having the config mismatch?
That is quirky. Yeah. You're right. You're right.
Temp,
Cilium.
Alright. Let's get out of here.
And then we wanna
so
you're saying if we delete Cilium, it'll redownload
up? Yeah. Do a rule at restart DaemonSet
Cilium or something like that.
Or delete them all. Whatever way you prefer
to to restart services, you go for it.
Do y'all wanna hint?
No. No. Not yet. I think we're close.
I think we're close. I can see you
sitting there laughing, though. I'm enjoying it. I
know.
It's funny because
I I'm not gonna say anything more, but,
I mean, what you said about chasing your
tail is absolutely
right.
Alright. So,
yeah, so like this.
Oh, but the problem is,
like, now now that we did that yeah.
Let's just do this anyways.
So k get pod. I understand.
Kube system. That's our yep. Kube system.
Alright. So we wanna get rid of
So is there anything in ops c and
I bin?
No. No.
So let's see. So we wanna roll out,
and then it's
set.
Restarting.
Oh, and then
That's the one?
And you're thinking There we go. Things are
coming back.
And then let's see.
And those are better time stamps than before.
So let's do version here,
and
so that's one ten.
And so I think over here,
you don't want zero three one. Right? Like,
we want one ten whatever?
Well, no. I think that's the CNI version
versus the Oh, yeah. You're right. CNI version.
Okay.
You're right. So now I need to figure
out what is the correct CNI version.
Right?
I I don't know. Run get pods. Do
we have anything yet?
Let's see. Oops. Sorry.
Let's get out of do
can you get prod?
No. Oh, so see yeah. So we need
to figure out what that correct CNI version
is. So I'm
you can't see my screen, but I'm googling
real quick to see what the correct CNI
version is.
Because, yeah, I feel like that CNI version's
modified, and we just need to know what
the
correct version is.
03One's
correct.
Can I just say that I did not
modify the CNIs in any way, shape, or
form?
Alright. Okay. I've not modified the CLI. Okay.
Which means we probably have to do an
app to re app install dash dash reinstall
Kubelet for any missing binaries then.
Oh, well, we got the We only got
two back. Yeah. So Yeah.
But we're still getting the same error. So
this is the error we're still chasing. Failed
to set up the
network for the sandbox,
And it's saying
the config is one point oh, incompatible CNI
versions. Config is one o, but plug in
supports
oh, no. No. So it's trying to use
the wrong CNI.
Right?
Incompatible CNI versions. Config is one l,
but zero three one is what we should
be on.
So where's that config at?
Don't know. I think we may have to
take that hint in a minute.
Yeah. So
trying to think. Like, where where would we
define what CNI version it's going to use
when
it do we have more than one?
You know?
Can I drop one hint for you?
Yeah. Go for it. I may I'll speak
to John if you want a hint, John.
Yeah. Yeah. Sure. Run
a kubectl get nodes dash o y.
Oh. Did
you upgrade one of the nodes to Kubernetes
one twenty four?
Yeah. Control
I don't think I changed the node
version. Yeah. Control Blane's one twenty four right
now, and then the worker's 123. It's
strange. I don't think I upgraded the node,
though.
Oh, that I guess that could have been
me a moment. No. I looked at the
re oh, I did that at the Yeah.
You just reinstalled that. Yeah. I've just
Yep.
Should be fine, though. Yeah. It should be
alright. Although, there's not like there was any
major deprecations on 01/24. Right? Oh, yeah. Not
like or anything. You look carefully at the
output.
The container d version is different.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
So, yeah, the worker is on a different
container d version.
Could that cause
problems? I actually wouldn't expect it to, but
I guess if the CNI
like, I can go to the worker and
downgrade.
Right? But
Yeah. Let's try it. See what happens.
What version was it on? 159 is what
we want. 59
is what we want.
And if it's I think it's just one
equals. Two equals. You're right. Is that two?
Okay.
Oh, I thought it was two.
Always giving bad advice.
It's on the newest version.
After reinstall on it, maybe they just replaced
the binary.
No. It still says so. Yeah. We we
need to actually do a reinstall.
Let's do version. Alright. So now that's there.
And then do I have crack control over
here?
That's not yeah. We need to go over
the other one. Alright.
So back to control plane.
I don't think that restarted container do you
look at it. Oh, no. Nope. You're right.
I'm on the control plane. I need to
go back to Rarker.
Yep.
K. Now back.
Hey.
Running.
There you go.
Eighteen seconds to spare.
That
surfaced itself in an interesting way
because it's saying that the CNI was a
different it wasn't compatible,
but it had nothing to do with the
CNI.
So I'm assuming container d is also,
must be what specifies the CNI version, and
there must have been a bump then from
to 1Dot0Dot0
with container D16,
I'm assuming. So that error was was actually
intentional.
I decided to use a nonworking version of
container d against this, Tilium CNI. It was
like a known bug. So you would have
either had to go up to one six
four
or revert back to +1 59.
Glad you got there, but if I hadn't
said anything about the KUKA, I
y'all would have been chasing a little bit
longer. Yeah. We've I we would have I
mean, I have Christmas. I haven't have caught
that. So and that's really know you both
gave us customers a stop to me completely,
which is great because this is this is
how we learned to invalidate some of those
assumptions we make along the way.
Yeah. That's the most fun I've had is,
like, the, like, breaks like this where it
tells you something, but it the the problem's
completely something else. Like so, like, the one
I did where I changed the scheduler amount.
It's like, oh, RBAC's broken. You don't have
the correct permissions, and it has nothing to
do with RBAC whatsoever.
I know. We need better error messages.
Yeah. That's that that is pretty telling because
you were you were basically chasing after a
CNI related version when, in fact, like, it
was had nothing to do with it. Right?
And it was pretty interesting to see. And
even the certificate one, like, if I hadn't
said anything about that,
it could have been going on for a
while. But it's not very verbose about where
to really look. Right? And that's like, okay.
Maybe we file a bunch of PRs against
the Kubernetes
ecosystem to say, let's make this a lot
more human human readable
so that we can troubleshoot better. Right? But
then again, this is why tools like Commodore
exist and whatnot.
Definitely.
Those error messages can be very
opaque at times, and I think, yeah, maybe
we should be using clusters as a means
to fail issues against some of this stuff
and see if we can get people to
open some pro request because
this stuff is already hard with the the
tooling fight against us at times. So, you
know,
well played both of you.
Alright. We're gonna wrap this up. Thank
you both for joining me. Those were two
terribly mean clusters, but you both absolutely smashed
it. Well done working through all of those
problems.
Bringing another cluster, it was just plain krill,
John. Yeah. Marino
finds an actual bug in container d and
bringing that to the party was equally as
krill. So well done.
Thank you to Equinix Metals. Thank you to
Teleport for their continued support. And we won't
be back next week because of KubeCon, but
I hope I do get to see some
of you there, and we'll be back the
following week with cluster team.
Alright. Any last words, John, Marino?
No. I had a lot of fun.
Yeah. I'd like to say the same. I
had a great time. I learned a lot.
In fact, learning on the fly as I'm
troubleshooting,
and we've got that pressure on top where,
like, why isn't it getting why isn't it
working? And you got people in the chat.
It was it was a very great experience.
So thank you so much for for setting
this up, David. And great meeting you, John.
This was fun. Well, I do need more
victims. I mean, volunteers. So anyone watching, if
you wanna come on clustered, get in touch.
Well, I feel like now that we're acquainted,
we can be more evil with each other.
So let's just do it again
with no holds bar.
Yeah.
That's an idea for future episodes, actually. Just
getting people back and say it right. The
rules are gone. Do your work.
We'll see. Alright. Let's go to Chris. Let's
go to Thank you again both. Have a
great time and a great day, and I'll
see you soon. Adios. Bye all. See you.